with dignity and respect
committed to free speech excellent sense
of beep and entertaining straight
talking and direct we may act eight each
other and you thought-provoking
provocative and controversial hello and
welcome to the pledge now they're been
plenty of scary things around this week
children dressed as witches and ghouls
for Halloween the Knights drawing in
after the clocks went back Philip
Hammond trying to crack jokes but
nothing compares to the fright I
experienced just now when I walked into
our green room and saw this lock without
any makeup
coming up greg has some questions for
spreadsheet Phil Carol thinks British
jihadi widows shouldn't be allowed home
nick says eat my shorts and June thinks
there's a bit of sparkle in the royal
family but first up it's me now to a
more serious matter as Donald Trump
visited the synagogue where eleven
American Jews were killed
protesters accused him of encouraging
white supremacist attackers like suspect
Robert dowas playing pin the tail on the
donkey after a tragic terrorist attack
is sadly a regular political sport
depending on perspectives no one is safe
Democrats aren't tagged for ignoring
grievances the media for whipping up
anger and outrageously the Pittsburgh
Jewish community themselves for being
Pro immigration this can all quickly
become too shrill Trump's daughter and
son-in-law are after all Jewish - and
Robert dows is no fan of the president
but just days after pipe bombs were sent
to CNN's offices mr. Trump once again
branded media has the enemy of the
people to speak in such tones
immediately after bombs were sent to the
media is totally irresponsible if we are
all held hostage to the bombing end of
our political leanings and every
political outlet has them then none of
us had better say anything at all but we
are directly responsible for our own
inflammatory language and it is here
that mr. Trump keeps failing
[Music]
Marty's you're not suggesting there's a
direct relationship between the Trump
rhetoric and these events in the United
States no no of course not that's why my
introduction was so caveated as I said
if we're all held hostage to the
fermions of our political leanings then
we can't even speak what I am suggesting
though is what we are directly
accountable for is our own inflammatory
language on its own terms and so though
there's obviously no connection between
the pipe bomb sent to CNN and the
president directly there's even less of
a connection with the sitting or
attacking the president however it still
is irresponsible to create a climate in
which hostility can I imagine encourage
or facilitate or produce those sorts of
attacks so my suggestion of course is
just to be a bit careful when describing
people as the enemy of the people
of course enemies involved war which
involves fighting but but that's how I
got elected
of course it got a lecture by losing
that sort of legs leg is being
interested in contrarian I imagine you
agree with me secretly Greg that we
should be careful about how we speak to
people and about P well I think the tone
of language is important and we should
be careful I doubt but I think it's too
big and jump to say the tone of language
like is lead I mean there's always been
nutters in America as you most countries
but particularly oh no no no I'm not
accusing mr. Trump of being and not
accusing me of all sorts of things but
I'm not sure it's an utter but but
therefore I think she wants yes what you
think you think he is responsible yeah
well you gotta be what he was in your
language shortly
totally I'm and I'd like to let me show
a clip when I was tell you why I do
think that there is a clear direct link
I love the old days you know what they
used to do to guys like that when they
were in a place like this they'd be
carried out on a stretcher folks like to
punch him in the face I'll tell you
they're bringing drugs they're bringing
crime they're rapists and some I assume
are good people and their agenda is to
elect crooked Hillary Clinton if she
gets to pick her judges nothing you can
do folks
although the Second Amendment people
maybe there is a I thought it was very
very appropriate he was swinging he was
hitting people and the audience hit back
and that's what we need a little bit
more of honestly she should be locked up
and I just want to say a couple of
things and then I'll hand over to faith
to avoid making Carol looking at me like
she had a couple of things so in the
case of the synagogue shooter his final
tweet before he went and murdered those
11 people and injured so many was that
he was going to specifically attack
that synagogue because of their stance
on immigration and in particular because
Muslims and particularly to Hayase
and the head of higher said and I
thought he put it so brilliantly he said
hateful language often leads to hateful
acts and what I will say Majid is at the
end of the day with all of the hysteria
that Trump was whipping up over that
so-called Caravan we are not surprised
that this happened this week in America
the other piece I would have ad is where
the pipe bomber is concerned the people
that that pipe bomber attacked are
people that have actually been called
out by Donald Trump as enemies and can I
just have pick up one last thing and
then I'll hand over a picture of the
pipe bombers van well what else okay
I've got that because I just want to
read you with tweet it this is this is
from a conservative commentator called
ben shapiro
and he says crazy person attacks
Republican Congress people blame the
crazy crazy person sends bombs to
Democrats blame the Republicans and he
was talking about last year you might
remember when Bernie
it was the Bernie Saunders support
brought into there burst into the
baseball practice with a gun and and
started firing at Republican congressman
so nobody blamed Bernie Saunders back
then and and while you know
while Robert Bowers is responsible for
the deaths of those 11 people nobody
else he's a crazy but but i but I do
concede that because of Trump there is
new extremism in politics that wasn't
there before there was a lot more
violence and anger but I think it's on
both sides of the ad because although we
were talking about Maxine Waters been
one of the she's one of the Democrat
that got the pipe bomb you know you know
remember what she said about about
people just just quite recently she said
that anyone who was in Trump's
administration if they walk into a bar
or a restaurant or a gas station people
have to crowd around them and force them
out and tell them they're not welcome
that's inflammatory language - and I
just I think it's happening on Thursdays
grievin do we agree then responsibility
stops with the person using the
inflammatory language and the problem is
they're inflammatory language even
though obviously the people in charge of
political parties on both sides they you
know people listen to what leaders say
and the thing about the thing about
Trump's tweets the violent tweets the
accusation is there that it's you know
what he is saying is inflaming people
who might start believing it's in New
York and he said a bit more brutalities
leader to a recipe well anyway Nick
wants to come in just to challenge Jun
because look he has sets of intemperate
things but I don't think I don't think
we can lay the actions what happened at
the synagogue the Pittsburgh that the
president made it like well then when
people when Islamist terrorists totally
misrepresent their faith and start
blowing people we don't blame is saying
people don't blame Islam or the Prophet
Mohammed it's people its people
misinterpret I mean of course bridge
right and President Trump is not added
to civility in this in his country or
indeed the entire world the language is
much much more brutal but to get to the
door of the synagogue I just can't go
that far down the pole I'm not on that
analogy just just a what I do know
personally is that if an Islamist
preacher in a mosque is saying gays
deserve to die in an IED or Caliphate
and then Isis are throwing them off
buildings we in the media do say that
Islam is a fanatic and is creating a
hostile environment for gays and
creating homophobia so where there's a
direct language link to an atrocity
we don't say they're responsive Cremona
say shoot the Jew
no but when you say media at the enemy
that people already going to need oh
that's awful you're addressing police
and you say a bit more brutalities
needed to arrest people you've got to be
held accountable for the language if
you're president you know this guy this
this nutter this Robert Bowers he
actually he was berating surprising that
he hadn't done enough about the quota
infestation what is interesting about
having created this language really in
politics in a way that we haven't seen
for many decades is their only way back
from it oh is that the way that the
political discourse hard to think of
going back to Obama days is about to
think about going back to that
convention Obama for balance we better
go to the White House now sorry to
interrupt no but let's hear what the
White House press secretary Sarah
Huckabee Sanders said quite soon after
the attack look there's a big difference
between comments made in actions taken
the president is certainly not
responsible for sending suspicious
packages to someone no more than Bernie
Sanders was responsible for a supporter
of his shooting up a Republican baseball
field practice last year the idea that
this is at the hands of the president is
absolutely and I think Carol that would
put the response to the tweet that you
read a few moments ago it's exactly the
same thing and also I think that you
know Trump's problem is that whereas
Obama was a national consoler
if there was some terrible tragedy
happened he was fantastic alone and but
I think with Trump's problem is because
it's downsize yeah but with trouble you
he can't convey empathy or compassion he
can't do that it sounds faith with him
and I you know he just can't do what we
did just a see the Trump's deployed a
very clever linguistic technique when he
speaks as well to sometimes be able to
have a level of plausible deniability
when it comes to some of this stuff
let's just watch this fascinating take
by somebody who's an expert on the
matter Trump has a habit of announcing
that he's not going to say something
while he's actually saying it so I
refuse to say that I cannot stand her
screaming into the microphone all the
time is this rhetorical device is called
Apple faces it lets Trump plant an idea
in people's heads without taking any
responsibility for what
say now once there was because of me but
it was okay I won't do it I was going to
say they're foolish but I won't say that
now it's true it's true I won't say this
mr. strategy allows Trump to present
himself as a lovable road
well that's behavioral psychologist dr.
Peter but his problem is as well as the
media are totally against him whatever
he says whatever he says it's never the
media and the papers are certainly
against them so even when he did express
revulsion at these attacks in the
synagogue he's he's complaining they
know when to Pittsburgh even though they
didn't want anybody would really care
what the deal was but he had to be dozen
if you're a president you've got to turn
a rock and a hard place